bonjour jean françois di muzio merci de
répondre à nos questions ce matin sur
arte france et discipline collective
nécessaire pourquoi une telle sémantique
et pourquoi maintenant alors que le lieu
semble plus que jamais divisés sur fond
de crise sanitaire
oui en fait d'abord elles dont il faut
rappeler dans quel sens aux antilles et
de représentants locaux projets
redondants quelque sorte l'équivalent du
ministre des affaires étrangères de la
production européenne c'est lui qui est
supposé parler ou non et 27
il est dans un contexte plusieurs
initiatives entreprises initiative par
les représentants des pays individuels à
pékin pour effectivement s'exprimer sur
la gestion de l'eau
en fait c'est un appel à l'union enfin
ça des initiatives un peu désordonnée à
la publication dans le china belgique à
divo maintenant et ses différentes
prises de position des ambassadeurs est
donc ce qui pourrait apparaître de
position j'appellerai ferme de l'europe
aussi une tentative d'ouverture au
dialogue monde a retenu effectivement
cette expression qu'on connaît
maintenant rival systémique
il faut se souvenir de ces défaillances
du battistini et a pu dans une série de
cape répression il définit la relation
d'union européenne des possibles est une
opération de coopération de rivalité
donc c'est très complexe
donc en fait il s'agit pour nous de
remettre les pendules à l'heure il ya
l'europe à travers moi est capable
d'avoir une sombre voire ya quelqu'un
est chargé de ça n'écoutez pas les
autres voies et sept mois c'est une voix
qui fait se veut absolument faire à en
harmonie est pourri qui présentait par
les ambassadeurs 15 mai en longue date
mais pas vocation à exprimer chacun de
leur côté une position européenne et
encore moins en tant qu'ambassadeur en
place a représenté des autorités que
l'on est supposé doucement représenté à
distance un petit peu sans complexe et
cet article c'est tribune dans le monde
qui est apparu qui est effectivement
importante parce que c'était la foi
puissions faire mais aussi
alors vous l'avez dit un la chine rivale
systémique
comment est ce que pékin accueille cette
sortie pas très bien en fait le
quatrième point de la coopération
européenne de l'année dernière c'est
celui qui porte et un système politique
il s'agit pas là de parler de
coopération de rivalité commerciale et
c'est le système politique
donc l'europe s'il ya un point sur
lequel l établissement fermé vis-à-vis
de la chine et son système de sociétés
ouvertes les sujets précédent vous avez
coupé en tout à fait allusion à cela
c'est à dire que le défi et savoure
comptait regarder des sociétés web où la
liberté de parole dont souffrent les
garanties il n'est pas garanti
en tout cas les instruments qui la
contrôlent donc supervisé par d'autres
instances à dire que lorsque l'on perde
une partie de nos libertés de fêtes
suivie de la contamination qui va être
fait par des applications de téléphone
24 ans tu as aussi que nos garanties la
capacité à faire valoir d'un pouvoir
et bien sûr tout ça qui est en jeu dans
l affaire parce qu'aujourd'hui la chine
est en train de se dire c'est nous qui
gagnons il ya un an comment est ce que
l'europe peut appliquer les
recommandations de rosette borel est ce
qu'elle en a réellement les moyens
alors effectivement c'est vous avez
aussi évoqué dans l'un de ses précédents
europe c'est bien sûr une institution
qui progresse dans les difficultés on
l'a souvent montré
on est en face d'une grande difficulté
aujourd'hui avec cette crise mais c'est
aussi un ensemble qui est procède par ko
avec deux dirait une petite lune
orthographe français c'est parfois
chaotique ici parfois on peut aussi donc
là avec l'espagne avec italie on a
l'exemple de pays qui se désolidarise il
faut impérativement qu'on y est pourquoi
pour appeler à une certaine vérité c'est
pas gagné c'est évident le rôle du haut
représentant aux affaires étrangères de
rugby amateur comme vous le savez il n'y
a pas de gouvernement d'europe
il ya plus deux personnes
essentiellement dix mois la patronne de
la commission la commission européenne
autour des greens depuis effectivement
nous pour commission aux collations
projet fonds peuvent parler
j'ai seulement roulera pour n'a pas de
boulot groupe en difficulté ces mois de
la fin merci jean françois di meglio
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes le président de
l'institut de recherche asia center on